is about to smash
smash macaroni he said may the almighty
disfigure the face of this creature
from a juvenile where my clothes had
holes in them
and my afro
macron as you can see back going to get
rinsed by khabib in a minute
khabib said something but what comes
that problem says i want to make
something very clear
[Music]
the fact that we see a group of people
attacking the prophet sallallahu assalam
be
from all kinds of backgrounds while
lighting it shows the power of islam
the fact that they have nothing better
to do they can't attack the quran
intellectually academically they cannot
but all they can do is insult the
prophet
while he destroys the power of allah now
a lot of muslims
want to go protest go and do all that
kind of stuff look
if there's one thing that we need to do
it's very simple
turn to your religion there is nothing
that hurts these people more than you
youngsters turn into religion
boycotts
so anyways i'm going to do another video
going into dwelling into the dark
history of france
french what they have done these
terrorists not all i'm not saying all
french
by the way but there's a different story
so let's read now what had to say
yeah he's about to smash smash macaroni
he said may the almighty disfigure the
face of this creature and all his
followers who under the slogan of
freedom of speech offend the feelings of
more than one and a half billion muslim
believers
may the almighty humiliate them in this
life and in the next allah is quick in
holding to account
and you will see it we are muslims we
love our prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi will sell
more than our mothers fathers children
wives and all other people close to our
hearts
believe me these provocations will come
back come back to them
the end is always for the god fearing
that is from habib
to macaroni macaron yeah whatever the
hell his name is yeah
brother says it's very very important
for us to understand there are people
who are emotional
and they go out there and carry out
attacks killing innocent people
so-called muslims who are on a different
psychological
zone yeah this is not the tradition of
the prophet sallallahu alaihi
this is not how the prophet sallam
taught us to behave we need to
intellectually academically equip
ourselves
and destroy these guys which you've seen
in the dawah scene with many dua
who have gone and do that we don't need
to resort to this the biggest form
of our weapon is what not the fist
not the knives not the weapons the quran
turn to the quran
and while everyone will fear us why
because it is the haqq
and because they fear that the only
thing that they can do against islam is
what
insults broken sisters check out my next
video inshallah as i discuss
french dark history so next time from
khabib
to macron i will smash semi location
salaam alaikum